bien sûr vous pouvez passer juste le
j'ai vu le démentil apparaître à l'écran
qui est très inéress oui exactement er
richerm s'il vous plaît merci petite
mise au point car je lis ici et là des
bêtises tout le monde journaliste inclus
connaissait la très courante pratique de
compte fake mais qu'on ne me fasse pas
dire que ce que je n'ai pas dit le
montage et trompeur à aucun moment je
n'ai fait de lien entre un compte et un
individu je n'ai donné ni confirmé aucun
nom de compte je n'ai d'ailleurs aucune
idée de qui tenait le compte repnat du
ghetto et à vrai dire je m'en fiche
voilà donc ça c'est important de le
montrer également visibleblement
il y a
Humo qui vous accuse de lui avoir
proposé quelque chose d'illégal regardez
vous avoir même d'avoir mis du temps à
payer ses prestations c'était un
conseiller voilà un conseiller en
communication et
regardez c'était une coquille vide
c'estd qu'en terme de fond il était
plutôt limite il ne lisait pas
particulièrement pour ce don je me
souviens il ne s'informait pas du tout
parce qu'il il ne reprenait que les
éléments de langage
pendant 4 mois le communiquant produit
notamment des clips pour sa campagne
37320 € de prestation au total mais pour
se faire payer il affirme que Jordan
Bardella lui aurait proposé un drôle de
marché je me suis fait balader pendant
des mois jusqu'au jour où il en est
arrivé à me dire bon écoute on va
essayer de trouver un système pour te
régler à moitié sur la les compes de
campagne à moitié sur le Parlement
européen un mode de paiement illégal qui
n finalement pas eu lieu payer un
prestataire de la campagne
présidentielle avec l'enveloppe des
eurodéputés s par entrer à un
détournement de fonds public alors
attendez on a trouvé un autre truc à lui
reprocher qui n'a pas eu lieu oui c'est
en fait vous saz c'est complément
d'enquête ça devrait s'appeler les
guignoles de l'info je pense qu'on
devrait renommer cette émission les les
guignoles de l'info donc là on a un
communicant on a un communicant qui
vient dévoiler en fait un peu comme un
médecin sous le SO du secret médical qui
vient dévoiler un peu les dessous des
cartes de sa de sa prestation
professionnelle donc à pour avoir des
des clients maintenant ça va quand même
être très compliqué donc tout est comme
ça en fait on est allé chercher quelques
personnes qu' ont travaillé avec nous
qui ne travaillent plus avec nous vous
savez comme c'est dans le milieu
professionnel ils ont pas eu ce qu'ils
voulaient ils partent ils développent de
la ranur c'est encore plus vrai en
politique et on a monté un reportage qui
n'a ni que ni tête ce qui me dérange
c'est que c'est c'est que l'impôt des
Français en fait combien ça a coûté
cionange pas moi combien ça a coûté aux
gens là les gens on on parle toujours
d'économie dans les dans les caisses de
l'État combien ça a coûté aux gens de me
traquer pendant un an entre 100 et
150000 €.
voilà entre 100 et 10000 € et encore je
compte pas tous
les euh tout ce qui euh tu mobilises du
du personnel pendant cette périodelà euh
par exemple les rédacteurs en chef de
l'émission bien sûr voilà donc euh bon
ils ont d'autres choses à faire par
ailleurs mais forcément oui en tous les
cas c'est entre 100 et 150000 € minimum
alors euh on va voir d'autres extraits
parce qu'il y a des extraits on va on va
revenir surt bien entendu complément
d'enquête tu as évoqué un autre sujet
c'est 2027 tout le monde se demande de
vous ce que vous réserve l'avenir si un
jour vous accédez au pouvoir Premier
ministre de Marine Le Pen ou successeur
d'Emmanuel Macron regardez Jordan
bardellaa il n'a que 27 ans est-ce qu'il
a les qualités d'un Premier ministre
potentiel pour devenir Premier minist
qualités mais il a même des qualités
pour être autre chose c'est ça la vraie
question qu'il faudrait que je me pose
Madame Le Pen me disait à l'instant vous
avez toutes les capacités pour être un
premier ministre potentiel c'est pas
vrai j'ai dit qu'il plus que
ça j'ai dit qu'il encore autre chose que
ça si vous pensez que je vais vous
répondre et en plus là maintenant je
pense que vous vous plantez si jeune et
déjà si
expérimenté devant notre caméra le
message est clair le successeur ce sera
lui ça vous a fait plaisir ça c'est un
bon moment ça pour vous quand même bah
c'est peut-être le seul moment agréable
parce que en fait faut bien se dire que
fait de la politique c'est difficile
c'est un un vrai sacrifice quand on fait
de la politique à ce niveau-là sur nos
libertés sur notre vie privée et les
méthodes de complément d'enquête le
rappelle et et c'est pas très agréable
en fait de de d'avoir je l'ai pas
regardé en direct je l'ai pas regardé en
direct je l'ai regardé pour préparer
votre émission je ne comptais pas le
regarder je l'ai regardé pour
préparermion j'ai V exès ce matin et je
l'ai regardé cet après-midi pour
l'émission mais c'est pas agréable voilà
par parce que vous savez que vous êtes
traqué ouais et et et c'est c'est même
si vous savez que vous avez rien à vous
reprocher vous avez toujours tout fait
de bonne foi vous vous dites que par
insinuation on pe tout dire et donc oui
bah c'est vrai que c'est moment de
complicité d'amitié avec Marine c'est
c'est peut-être le seul moment agréable
entre guillemets de pas fait de soirée
avec des amis tout ça pour le regarder
j'ai fait une soirée avec des amis mais
pas pour regarderi moi j'avais réuni
tout le monde on av regardé je vous
J on a regardé j'ai adoré moi le moment
du bateau tout
ça le moment du bateau bateau il ont
parlé génial je me suis régalé oh moi
j'étais mais moi j'étais j'ai
l'impression ah le nouveau Parin du P ah
oui génial ah ouaischement ah ouis la
photo est folle j'étais comme un fou moi
ouis ah ouis la photo est meilleure que
la mienne je me le repasse plusieurs
foisadore j'adore j'adore ça c'est mon
émission préférée je le dis c'est mon
émission préférée vous je vous sens
quand même un peu non je vous jure que
c'est vrai et je le dis par que on peut
en parler c'est V que moi aussi voilà il
il est passé il y a pas longtemps c'est
vrai qu'il y a plein de gens qui me
disent est-ce que tu as été touché par
le complément d'enquête et je leur dis
mais les gars j'adore et je le pense
vraiment c'est une de mes émissions
préférées j'adore parce que vraiment
c'est c'est 1h3 de rien voilà donc
c'était je j'ai l'impression que ça vous
a un peu agacé un peu touché
euh bah ce qui m'a pas pas agacé mais
mais mais c'est dur de vous dire que
pendant un an vous êtes on analyse le
moindre de vos faits et gestes on va
s'intéresser au aux gens qui ont partagé
ma vie ça qu'on va regarder euh qui qui
sont vos ex on s'intéresse à la famille
de vos ex on va vérifier si quand vous
avez été jeune vous avez travaillé pour
le Parlement européen moi j'ai j'ai eu
un contrat 3 mois comme assant
parlementaire il y a rien pasquête j
rien mais on se demande si quand même
vra mais on voit qu'il même le
journalisme sérieux ils ne le font pas
j'étais absent au Parlement européen
parce que j'étais assistant local et
donc ma mission consistait à travailler
à Paris et non pas aller au Parlement
europeéen ont dit ça aussi ils ont dit
que vous étiez par mais voilà c'est
beaucoup d'insinuation et et et en fait
ils sont ils sont très vicieux parce
qu'avec rien ils peuvent créer une
histoire et quand vous faites de la
politique vous savez qu'aujourd'hui en
fait on est tous c'est les preuve des
poteaux de colonta c'est qu'on est tous
sur des poteaux on se fait dégommer un
par un et en fait au fond à la fin celui
qui qui gagne c'est celui qui tient
c'est celui qui reste deboutund et et je
sais pas si c'est mundir norm en tout
cas mundir il a il il a perdu le
contrôle à un moment donné qu'on n pas
le droit de faire nous alors euh vous
revenez aussi il reviennent aussi sur la
fois vous auriez voulu défier Marine Le
Pen mais sans succès comme le raconte
Philippe Vardon j'aimerais bien que vous
reveniez làdessus que vous nous racontez
ça vraiment regardez en février 2023 il
dénonce la naïveté collective à l'égard
des ambitions de Vladimir Poutine et
parle M même de faute morale voulait-il
tester son poids dans le parti c'est
l'analyse qu'en fait Philippe Vardon son
ancien conseiller en stratégie il a
tweeté son interview pour voir qu'il
soutenait et là il y a personne il y a
quatre députés qui retweetent son truc
sur 89 quoi ce qui veut dire qu'il n'est
pas reconnu comme une puissance dans le
parti je me suis dit waouh le moment de
faiblesse que ça incarne il lui faut des
élus des fédérations derrière lui il en
est complètement
dépourvu alors ça Philippe Vardon on en
parlait tout à l'heure souhaite déposer
plainte contre complément d'enquête
parce qu'il dit ne jamais avoir tenu ses
propos c'est fou parce que c'est ce
qu'il a dit regardez voici près d'un an
j'ai été contacté par un journaliste de
complément d'enquête écoutez bien ce
tweet qu'il a publié aujourd'hui
Philippe Vardon écoutez bien parce que
là il peut pas avoir que des gens qui
disent n'importe quoi non plus c'est ce
qui est fou c'est parce que complément
d'enquête tout ce qu'il disent eux c'est
on doit le prendre pour argent comptant
et tout ce qui est dit contre eux ce
sont des bêtises et ce sont de de
fausses infos il il a tweeté je pense
pas que ce garçon euh ait envie de de de
si si c'était pas vrai je pense pas
qu'il aurait tweeté voici près d'un an
j'ai été contacté par un journaliste de
complément d'enquête lors d'une
rencontre je lui ai fait part de mon
refus catégorique de participer de
quelque manière que ce soit à ce
reportage contre Jordan Bardella
d'ailleurs il dit contre Jordane
Bardella dis pas sur Jordane Bardella
donc chacun sait que j'ai c-irigé la
campagne en 2019 puisque l'équipe de
complément d'enquête prétend que
j'aurais donné un accord j'ai chargé mon
avocat d'étudier des poursuites pour me
convaincre de participer au reportage et
faire pression sur moi ce journaliste a
menacé de diffuser une vidéo largement
connue il a près de 30 ans désormais
j'avais 15 ans sur laquelle j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de m'expliquer d'exprimer mes
profonds regret et qui ne correspond en
rien à l'homme qui s'est bâti depuis et
que je suis aujourd'hui minable oui
carrément ce doit être la fameuse
déontologie du service public
audiovisuel j'imagine donc ils ont fait
du chantage euh euh euh Jacques cardose
vous qui avez travaillé là-bas est-ce
que c'est possible ça c'est incroyable
ça dit ça aujourd'hui d là les mecs
c'est n si c'est vrai c'est extrêmement
grave par il y a quelque chose qu'on a
pas dit sur l'anonyme euh ch chaque
journaliste travaille avec sa conscience
mais normalement lorsque tu produitis
une interview anonyme il faut pouvoir
avoir la preuve quand même au cas où il
y a un procès de dire bah c'est anonyme
sauf que moi j'ai quelqu'un donc si vous
portez plainte contre moi je vais
divulguer mes identités moi
personnellement je travaille comme ça
c'est-à-d que si je produis de l'anonyme
ça veut dire que derrière j'ai des j'ai
j'ai les identités des gens ouais tu
comprends ce que je veux dire vous le
savez il y a des si jamais c'est
totalement F alors là c'est extrêmement
grave par les gens non non pas ça Vardon
on en pense qu'on veut là on parle pas
de Vardon on parle des méthodes voilà je
vois des gens qui disent oui Vardon dit
je n'ai
Jon est un et oui mais on a pas dit
qu'on on a pas dit qu'on adhéit aux
idées de de Vardon on disait juste que
Vardon dénonce les vidéos voilà et donc
il y a des gens qui disent oui mais
c'est les gars c'est pas on dénonce pas
la personne on dénonce les méthodes
voilà aujourd'hui c'est ça qu'on fait
donc apparemment il il l'aurait il
aurait il aurait fait du chantage c'est
extr
pas vraiémentqu il on en tous les cas il
a tout intérêt à porter
PL ça commence à faire beaucoup chaque
personne qui témoig dans le reportage
l'une porte plainte l'autre en fait j'ai
[Musique]
jamais are extrait
Jordan je obligé de mettre
lien supposé avec des militants
d'extrême droite violente naz à çavec
qui grand de cous conna la
boulangre sous la bère du groupuscu
racist antisémite viol des centes
deitextrme droite parou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans les rangs Axel louau un vieux
copain de la patronne son ancien
trésorier alors Jordane qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça d'abord il d'abord ce
que je trouve malhonnête c'est qu'après
cette manifestation du GUD et et ils
auraient pu avoir l'honnêteté de passer
l'extrras j'ai demandé la
dissolution de tous les grospes
d'extrême droite y compris celui qui
manifestait ici deuxièmement Axel
Loustau a été prestataire de service
pour le rassemblement national la
dernière fois qu'il a eu une prestation
de service avec le rassemblement
national c'était en
2017 donc je veux bien qu'on tourne
autour du pot mais moi c'est pas mes
idées c'est pas ma tendance et c'est pas
ma manière de faire de la politique donc
encore une fois on me reproche d'être
dans un parti qui à un moment donné a eu
un un lien avec une personne qui était
actionnaire d'un d'une société de
communication qui s'est retrouvé à cette
manifestation si on fait ça pour tous
les actionnaires de tous les
prestataires de toutes les chaînes de
tél et de tous les partis politiques
franchement on va en apprendre quant au
Gude il y a des gens qui ont été au GUD
quand ils étaient plus jeune mais il y
en a dans tous les mouvements politiques
et il y a même des gens notamment à
droite qui sont devenus ministres comme
Monsieur Longuet qui lui a participé du
G quand il était jeune qui a eu un
engagement radical quand il était jeune
et qui est devenu ministre de la
République
française voilà si vouz point final je
n'ai pas de lien en fait avec cette avec
cette idéologie avec cette mouvance euh
le complément d'enquête on va dire un
dernier mot dessus aujourd'hui mais
juste il y a quelques mois vous étiez
sur ce plateau face à Gabriel Atal
devenu premier ministre on avait parlé à
l'époque de duel des dauphin vous pensez
quoi de sa
nomination moi je le jugerai à ce qu'il
fera d'cord voilà c'estd que j'ai j'ai
de la considération personnelle pour
pour lui c'est bien ouais euh ce ne sont
pas mes idées on a eu l'occasion de
faire beaucoup de débats ensemble
maintenant je crains que rien ne change
il vous avez rencontré aujourd'hui j'ai
été reçu à Matignon aujourd'hui alors il
vous a dit quoi alors c'est il a le
complément d'enquête ou pas hein il
regardé compl alors on n pas parlé du
complément d'enquête en revanche moi je
lui ai parlé de d'une chose qui m'a
paraît très importante c'est que le 1er
février le gouvernement a prévu
d'augmenter les tarifs de l'électricité
de 10 % et je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens aujourd'hui qui ont du mal à
boucler les fins de mois sûr et je lui
ai demandé solennellement de renoncer à
cette augmentation des prix de
l'électricité parce que je pense que ça
serait la goutte de trop pour beaucoup
de familles françaises et pour nos chefs
d'entreprise ok il m'a donné rendez-vous
à son discours de politique général don
rendez-vous dans 10 ans comme P
peut-être qu'on se retrouvea dans 10 ans
non mais et j'ai l'impression et moi
aussi je l'aime bien en plus vous aimez
bien quand même Gabriel Atal vous
l'aimez bien en tant que personne mais
si vous voulez j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
rencur ou de haine personnelle c'est on
peut ne pas avoir les mêmes idées
politiques et se resp moi mais non mais
c'est pareil à chaque fois que je viens
chez vous avec Gilbert avec gilverd
c'est toujours très compliqué mais mais
humainement j'ai pas de difficulté à
discuter avec vous c'est ça qui fait la
riche mais on l'aime bien aussi donc
gabrielal c'est c'est pas mes idées mais
je le respecte comme personne et je le
combattrai politiquement mais ça
m'empêche pas de le respecter et c'est
vrai avec tout le monde d'ailleurs je le
sectarisme on le fait que le subir nous
hein c'est je suis pas la France
insoumise Mo surou merci euh ça fait du
bien merci allez faire un tour avec Gill
verd il va vous présenter des amis juste
Jordan Bard un dernier mot sur
compliment d'enquête alors c'est quoi
c'est beaucoup de bruit pour rien c'est
quoi vous attendiez vous attendeiez à
pire vous attendeiez à mieux vous
attendeiez à quoi de bah tout ça pour ça
c'est ça mais maintenant vous êtes
tranquille vous savez que l'avantage
c'est qu'on ne trouvera pas une
casserole dans 10 ans quoi ah bah ça
c'est sûr 10 ans 1 an à être lasérisé je
pense que là à priori B va très bien je
clean bon vous être content
alors content non demain je vais en
déplacement je serai à côté de nos
agriculteurs B je peux vous mettre g
veris avec vous B venezoup un peu de
terrain surtout un vrai mouvement de
colère chez les agriculteurs les
agriculteurs je le dis tiens apporter
not n Nour vraiment vraiment vraiment
soutenir les agriculteurs on on dit
depuis très longtemps bien j'y serai
demain et Ben et ben allez-y merci à
tous allez
t c'est le monastère merci à tous à
lundi on vous aime mer les Ch